biden harris this is the most radical
this is the most extreme
this is the most far left out of the
mainstream
ticket of any modern american political
party
in history and guess what it looks like
reality is now
finally beginning to set in for ever so
slow and forgetful joe as his campaign
is devolving into a full-blown panic
tonight
just yesterday's campaign press
secretary at a complete
on-air meltdown and disaster
when asked simple questions by our own
brett bear
simple questions about biden's position
on the china travel ban did you support
it when
donald trump implemented it which he
didn't whether joe needs a teleprompter
to get
through softball interviews because look
at this recent interview
fine gets the question move it up move
it up
take a look i would like to know
what will your administration do to help
them give them that chance
thank you let's move it up here
you know there used to be a basic
bargain in this country
workers shared in the wealth their work
helped create
oh move it up move it move it up
and it gets worse because biden tonight
caught in yet another lie
new york post exposing his history of
falsely claiming that he predicted the 9
11 attacks remember joe
even imposed the bin laden raid last
night biden reportedly had another
bizarre moment
telling a campaign fundraiser that he
hopes the debates
don't devolve into an all-out brawl
really joe
if i were you you might want to focus on
figuring out how much coffee you're
going to drink the day of the debate
uh and how you're going to answer a
question without a teleprompter move it
up move it up please guys move
okay because of course biden has a
history of this sort of vicious rhetoric
as other democrats do
remember biden take a look the press
always asked me don't i wish i were
debating him
no i wish you were in high school i
could take him behind the gym
that's what i wish i i made i didn't
make a mistake but
they asked me would i like to debate
this gentleman
and i said no i said if we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of him
that's so joe joe probably just fall
over by the way
not just biden every corner of this new
radical extreme democratic socialist
party
they've been caught spreading nonstop
hatred
and rage and encouraging well what we've
been witnessing well over a hundred days
now
and guess what we'll just give you a
small sample
sadly the domestic enemies to our voting
system
and our honoring our constitution are
right at 1600 pennsylvania avenue with
their allies in the congress of the
united states
you see anybody from that cabinet in a
restaurant
in a department store
[Music]
they're not going to stop before
election day in november and they're not
going to stop after election day
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels that this
isn't they're not going to let up and
they should not i i just don't even know
why there aren't uprisings all over the
country and maybe there will be
i'll put mr burgess up against uh sean
hannity
he'll tear him up that's obama
threatening me good thing i'm not part
of the woke generation
ask yourself after hearing all this
democrats sound an awful lot like
they're encouraging
what we've been witnessing playing out
in cities in the streets all across the
country
and of course denying the reality well
responsibility
to these democrats and joe biden have
for refusing to condemn
the rioting denying it for months and
now it comes as what barely there
forgetful joe
and his campaign continue to spin in a
million different directions
flipping and flopping and flailing on
everything from fracking to the travel
ban
to policing to violent rioting that he
called mostly peaceful
even manufacturing and trade he's lying
about
listen to biden yesterday talking about
support for the failed nafta deal
that trump renegotiated not him and not
barack
and guess what they didn't do criminal
justice reform they didn't do
police reform they didn't do opportunity
zones and they didn't shatter
every record low unemployment for
african americans hispanic americans
asian americans
women in the workplace youth
unemployment african-american youth
unemployment
no their recovery let's see the worst
since the 40s
13 million more americans on food stamps
8 million more in poverty joe
that's after eight years you're as vice
president what have you accomplished in
50 years joe
anyway take a look we renegotiated nafta
and you didn't is the point i mean
because we had a republican congress
that wouldn't go along with us
renegotiating it
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the usmca is better
than nafta
it is better than nafta whoops
trump's better than biden yeah his plan
worked out much better ask yourself this
why is now biden changing his tune
trying to misdirect voters because let's
see biden
doesn't actually believe in anything he
is a professional
all talk no action politician the total
embodiment
of all things the washington swamp and
sewer
all talk all talk all promises gets
nothing done he was vice president for
eight years
i can't think of a single thing that he
did in that time
to make americans lives better donald
trump
kept all his promises and the struggles
don't stop there
because the ever slow forgetful joe is
behind on enthusiasm behind on policy
and his polls are collapsing
after embracing of course bolshevik
bernie socialism
and the economy killing green new deal
and his plan goes beyond that
pledging trillions in the new green deal
so he's now being forced to try and
erase his past positions rewrite history
daily
and the mob in the media they just
ignore it all pretending like he never
said
that he was in favor of redirecting
funds away from the police and saying
the police become the enemy and
trying to pretend that he never said
he'd ban fracking
not once not twice but numerous times
and trying to pretend like he's actually
accomplished something after being in
washington nearly 50 years
and of course the show will continue to
do the job the mob and the media will
never do
actually tell you the truth vetting the
candidate
joe biden because guess what biden
already
put down his far left wish list it's on
paper
in stated promises he made with the with
bolshevik bernie himself
the bolshevik bernie biden manifesto
released this summer
lays out and all the detail you ever
want the new
extreme radical socialist lawless
democratic party's plans for your future
110 pages outlines massive tax increases
trillions of new increases trillions in
new spending for the new green deal
madness wide open borders it's
essentially an all-encompassing welfare
state
where everything basically is free which
means that it'll be funded by you
we the american people the taxpayers now
these are
biden stated promises that he's put in
writing
the manifesto makes clear that pretty
much everything is a human right
page 17 no one should have to spend more
than 30 percent of their income for
housing
who's going to pay for the rest of that
mortgage that sounds like it was written
by
congresswoman ocasio-cortez the document
proves that biden shares a
vision similar to bolshevik bernie on
health care
establishing a heavily subsidized
government-run public option
how did obamacare work out biden also
vows to implement
a version of this new green deal that
will go further than ocasio-cortez's new
green deal
and putting ocasio-cortez on his climate
unity task force
and phasing out all fossil fuels in 15
years
that would be the lifeblood of the
world's economy and additionally
biden wants hundreds of millions of new
solar panels had cylindrical work out
which we know will mean higher energy
prices for
all businesses and every american and by
the way
we'll now be dependent on outside energy
again
and while the plan doesn't explicitly
call for dismantling the police
biden and bernie they want to quote
civilian
core of unarmed first responders
okay we're going to send in a
psychiatrist into a potentially violent
situation
domestic dispute community policing what
exactly does that mean
and sounds an awful lot like defunding
the police
like he said he'd do and the biden
bernie manifesto
also calls for the elimination of cash
bail you know they did that in new york
okay anarchists get arrested they get
sent out the same night to
rejoin the activities which has been a
complete disaster
allowing violent criminals back out on
the street with zero consequences
they were having bank robberies go on
guy gets robs a bank gets caught licks
let out goes out robs another bank doing
it five six times in new york city
biden claims to care the most about
vulnerable communities
his education plan would take away all
choice
from poor and working families with the
worst school districts
for example he wants to burden charter
schools with more government regulation
he makes it clear that school choice
programs don't have much of a future in
joe biden's america
same guy that didn't want uh integration
of schools because he didn't want his
kids going to schools that
were quote racial jungles and get this
no standardized testing because biden
and bernie they want to eliminate that
too
how do we know how the kids are doing on
immigration biden doubling down on open
borders
amnesty the united sanctuary states of
america he wants to end construction of
the border wall wants to end the
president's remain
in mexico policy which has reduced
asylum fraud to this country
and is perhaps the president's greatest
first term policy achievement
in other words biden kamala harris they
want us to be the united sanctuary
states of america just like
kamala's state of california along with
implementing a hundred day moratorium on
any
deportation what does it all mean it
means that
all of this is a preview of coming
attractions he's telling you what his
agenda is
is america listening the destructive
agenda
that joe biden is stating and his
supporters have
put on paper they're ready to unleash
all of this if they
win in 53 days biden can try and hide it
all
the media is certainly doing the work
for him but it's still out there if they
still
wrote it down on paper that's still
their stated plan
make no mistake biden and harris they're
ready they're willing they're able to
surrender
to the radicals that are them and their
now entire party
and by the way all of this you decide in
53 days